Good. Okay. Okay. Okay. So if you would just we'll start by having you state your name and
state and location. My name is Steve Lawson. Today is August 26th, 2011 and we're in a conference
room at the Valley Library. Okay. Today we'll be talking primarily about your interactions with
one is calling specifically trying to get a better sense of calling sort of personal character
at this. But before we get into that, two people you have like you talked a little bit about your life
starting out with sort of a thumbnail sketch of your biography before you into the LCI 1977.
I was born in Pennsylvania in 1951 and lived there for the first few years of life. I remember
collecting donations for the Little League. World Championship is typically held in Williamsport,
Pennsylvania and Little League is big activity in that area of North Central, Pennsylvania.
We moved to Massachusetts along the coast north of Boston in the mid to late 1950s. I'm not
exactly sure of the date. But I went through elementary school and high school in Totsfield,
Massachusetts, which is a town in Essex County very close to the sea coast. We lived in Ipswich,
originally, which is a coastal town in Essex County. After graduation from high school,
I went to Stanford University and I was there in Palo Alto from 1969 to 1973. I started work at the
Linus Poly Institute of Science and Medicine in 1977 and took a full-time job there in February of 1978
and had a number of different job titles there through the years. Eventually, we'd be coming chief
executive officer in 1993 about a year before Linus Poly died and have worked at the institute
for most of my career. What led you to develop your interest in science or
the university member of the career? Well, that's an interesting question. I was a little
rudderless, I would say, in college. It was very difficult for me to focus on a career. Some of my
friends were very career-oriented and became physicians and lawyers, went on to business school,
and so forth. That's pretty typical for an environment of academic excellence like Stanford
University. There were a lot of high achievers there. And I myself was a high achiever, of course,
in high school. California was a big adventure for me coming from the relatively state and
conventional East Coast. And it was very wild time to be in California in 1969 through 1973,
both culturally and politically. It was a lot of anti-war activity and sentiments. And, of
course, the counter-culture was really thriving in California at that time. In high school, I was
very interested in science and took advanced calculus and physics and chemistry and biology.
With the idea of perhaps becoming an architect, which led me to apply to Rensselaer Polytechnic
Institute as one of my college choices because they had a very strong department of architecture.
Stanford, at the time, had a department of architecture as well. And I decided ultimately to go
to Stanford. And after I got there within a year, they had completely dismantled the department
of architecture. So that pretty much pulled the rug out from under me with respect to that
initial potential career choice. I like science very much. I've always liked science very much.
I've always been very curious about nature and how things work. And I think with respect to
a career in the Linus Poly Institute, although I was relatively naive about Linus Poly in high
school and even in my early years in college, I had been taking vitamin supplements beginning in
high school. Actually, my mom gave me one a day multivitamin supplements beginning probably when
I was just a kid. But then in the high school years, my friends and I got very interested in
supplements. And we're taking vitamin E and vitamin C and things like that. So the whole
mission of the Linus Poly Institute really resonated with me. And that led me to a position there
in 1977 that really was not science oriented at that time. It was more related to analysis of
the direct male program, which had been implemented within a few years before I joined the institute.
And it provided a relatively steady income for a lot of the non-grant supported research that
was going on at the institute, which of course in those days was most of the institute's research.
So between my graduation from Stanford and the time I joined the institute, it was a fairly
carefree and adventurous time. I spent a year after graduation traveling around the country
visiting family and friends in Florida and Georgia and Maine and New England. I wanted to see
the country. I'd been very impressed with John Steinbeck's books, travels with Charlie and others.
And also Jack Kerawak, who grew up and is now buried in the same area in which I grew up in Massachusetts.
So both of those writers had a very strong influence, I think, on me and my desires for
experience and adventure in the United States. When I returned to California, after traveling around
for a year or so, I took a series of jobs that really were not technical in nature at all.
Cost of living in those days was very low. I think for $100 a month, I could cover my living expenses
quite easily. And I was not, as I said, career oriented at the time. So I did not feel compelled
to go to graduate school or begin a career in earnest at that time and I didn't.
It wasn't until I joined the institute that I really started to focus more specifically on science,
which at that time really thrilled me.
Were there any, you mentioned your interest in supplements when you were in college and I
assumed that pollen was probably something you were aware of at least by the time you had
graduated? Was that true? And were there any other signs of their role models or mentors you had
during that time, dearly, from the money? Well, I began taking vitamins probably in an irregular way
when I was in high school, probably a senior in high school. And that continued on into my
early years in college. Of course, pollen had written vitamins in the common cold in 1970,
and friends of mine had open health food stores and had supplement products as part of their
merchandise or sales. So I was aware of this whole field, early on, without really knowing
specifically much about Linus Pauley. As a matter of fact, I knew very little of Linus Pauley,
even when I went to Stanford as a freshman. It wasn't until
probably about 1972 that I became more aware of him and it didn't have anything to do with science.
At the time, I don't believe he was teaching undergraduate courses in chemistry at Stanford,
which would have been my possible exposure to him. I don't think he was teaching graduate level
courses at Stanford either. But he was very politically active. And of course, this was during a lot
of pretty vehement anti-war protests around the country. Stanford was no exception to that kind of
activity. And in particular, there was a tenured professor of English, H. Bruce Franklin,
who was a Melville scholar, one of the world's foremost authorities on Melville, and has subsequently
done a lot of work in recognizing science fiction as an appropriate academic discipline for study.
And he had joined the Revolutionary Union and also Vence Aramos, which was an organization I believe
based in Redwood City, California. There were very politically active. They were kind of
Maoist organizations, and they really wanted not only an end to the Vietnam War, but I think more
dramatic upheaval in the federal government at that time. And Stanford eventually had had
enough of H. Bruce Franklin and considered, I think, some of his activities borderline legal,
and Franklin was getting in a lot of trouble. And they decided to fire him. And of course, he was
a tenured professor. So that was a big ordeal in protocol that they had to work through in order to
fire him. Stanford trustees at the time were quite conservative. And I remember walking to class
down at the Quadrangle at Stanford, and I saw a protest outside the president's office.
And there were a group of undergraduates and other people assembled around a couple of people
waving protest signs. And the signs had something to do with the university had no right to fire,
a tenured professor for his political activity. And I saw these two fellows holding these signs,
and they looked grandfatherly to me at the time. And one was Linus Pauling, and the other one I
believe was Hal Holman, who was chairman of the Department of Medicine at Stanford University
Medical Center, who was a liberal and a good friend of Linus Pauling's at the time. And I remember
being very impressed with the fact that these two elderly gentlemen were taking the time out
from their busy schedules to go and actually protesting in front of the president's office. I
thought that was quite remarkable because at that time most of the political activity was
concentrated among very young people. Sometimes it was very random and chaotic and
encoed as well, but I thought it was quite remarkable that there were older people who were also
interested in demonstrating for the rights of people to express their political opinions. So that
was my first, that was really my first awareness of Linus Pauling was from the political perspective,
and not really from the scientific angle. It wasn't until I joined the Linus Pauling Institute that
I really became much more familiar with Linus Pauling's work in chemistry and in biology.
What was your area of study?
Well, when I joined, when I went to Stanford, as I mentioned, I was very interested in
architecture as a potential career. So I was taking engineering and architecture while that
department lasted. And I also had kind of a renaissance concept of undergraduate education at the time.
I thought it was very important to take as many courses and different subjects as possible. So I
was taking calculus and biology and art history and literature and poetry and just everything that I
thought I should be exposed to as an undergraduate. I graduated with degree in anthropology in 1973,
but I probably had almost enough credits and biology for a degree in biology or at least a minor in
biology. And at the time, there were a couple of pretty notorious professors at Stanford who made
a big impression on me. One was Colin Pitendrig in the biology department. He, I believe, also was
director of the Hopkins Marine Station in Monterey, taught a terrific course in biology and also
Cachadorian. William DeMent taught a very popular course in sleep and dreams that was very popular
among undergraduates. Phil Pzenbardo, of course, was teaching very popular psychology course at the time.
And he went on to some famous, the leader of the Stanford Prison Experiment, which was quite
influential at the time. How did you come to know about the landfilling institute and the job
you were doing in life for? Well, I had lived in Memel Park, Palo Alto for many years. The institute
was founded in 1973 on Sandhill Road, opposite the Stanford linear accelerator. And at that time,
that part of Sandhill Road, primarily the northern side of Sandhill Road, headed west, was a
series of relatively new buildings on Tom Ford property. He was a trustee of Stanford University.
And there were publishing companies and real estate companies and insurance companies.
Now that area is a high of venture capitalist activity. But the institute, in those days,
I believe the 2700 Sandhill Road shared relatively modern office building with Kemper Insurance Company.
And I was aware of the sign out on the street. So I'd driven by there many times on my way to the
coastal range or to the beach. And I think that if I remember correctly, I saw an advertisement in
the paper specifically for a job without a lot of detailed description about the nature of the job.
And I went to interview at the Linus Plain Institute of Science and Medicine and interviewed with
Art Robinson, who was then the president and director of the institute. And he hired me.
Do you recall the first time that you met Linus Plain?
Well, the first time I saw him, of course, was, as I said back in about probably 1972 when he was
demonstrating against the firing of H. Bruce Franklin. I met him in 1977 because my office was
just off the hallway that Pauling took to get to his office, which was adjacent to Art Robinson's
office, and also the accountant and controller were down at the end of that office as well.
And he was very aware of who was working at the institute and what all the activities were.
And he stopped in to introduce himself to me when I was sitting in my office one day. And of course,
I was, I had remembered him from Stanford and I had become more aware of his scientific legend,
of course, by then by working at the Linus Plain Institute. And I was also aware of the fact that
this was his institute and it was named after him. So of course, I had, I had high regard for him
as being the founder of this organization that I was now working for. But he impressed me as a very
warm, charming, very friendly person. He was not cerebral or distant at all, not a luth. He was very
very welcoming.
What he frequently around the institute, I mean, I know he traveled a lot, but we recall him being
of regular presence on a really nice day.
He did travel quite a lot, but I do remember him being a regular presence. Certainly when he was
in town, he would come by the institute that was his office and his main base of operations.
And if he had to do interviews or see guests, it was typically at the Linus Plain Institute in his office.
And I remember meeting many of his friends at that time, including an emissary from St. George's
lab at Woods Hole. I believe his name was. I can't think of his name right now. It started with a P.
It was very interesting in telling us about St. George's new theories regarding vitamin C and
the electronic basis of life. Vitamin C is an electron donor being very essential to life far
above its role in preventing scurvy or as an antioxidant. Dorothy Hodgkin also came through the
institute at that time and it was fairly soon after I arrived at the institute that I also met
you in Cameron, who of course was a Scottish surgeon who was collaborating intensively with
Linus Pauling on vitamin C and cancer work. Did you meet Dorothy Hodgkin? I did. I met Dorothy Hodgkin.
At that time, I believe I was working in the laboratory. I had begun a friendship with a
biochemist named Alan Sheetz at the institute as well as Dick Willoughby who was a biologist working
on the skin cancer and vitamin C experiments that Pauling had designed and were being carried out
by Art Robinson at the time. And as arts influence in the institute started to wane, people responsible
for a lot of the biological and biochemical work were encouraging me to get more involved in that work.
I seemed to have the aptitude for it. I was quite interested in it. So I moved out of the role
that I was originally hired to perform at the institute, which was this direct male solicitation
work and analysis into kind of a research assistant position in the labs. And that led me to come
in contact with people that Pauling would bring through the laboratory to show them the work that
we were doing. Bill Abarth at the time was running a volcano source field ionization mass spectrometer,
which was used for metabolite profiling, which was a big chunk of the institute's research at the time.
So people were always interested in coming down to the first floor and seeing that
rubbed goldberg contraption, which was always undergoing tinkering. Never seemed to be quite ready
for routine biological experimentation. And since I was working in the laboratory at that time,
I would meet people that Pauling would bring through the laboratory. And one of them with Dorothy Hodgkin.
So Pauling, you were hired in 1977 at LPI and have built a career there. Pauling lived until 1994.
So that's a 17-year period. And one of you can just generally characterize your relationship with Pauling.
How did you evolve over those 17 years? Sure. Well, originally I saw
little of him because my work did really not overlap with his research interests. I mean, of course,
he was heavily involved in the financial status of the institute. And Art Robinson was the main force
behind the Direct Mail solicitation program. But Pauling was certainly aware of that. And
once I started working in the laboratory more, we had more to talk about. And I became heavily involved
in the skin cancer and hairless mice program, which was testing the effect of different levels
of vitamin C in a mouse-chow diet on the development of skin cancer in hairless mice exposed to
ultraviolet light. And other arms of those experiments. And there were a number of experiments that
took place over a number of years. Some of the other arms of that project involved feeding raw food
and nuts to mice to see whether that also inhibited the development of skin cancer when the mice
were exposed to ultraviolet light. So the mice were given things like carrots and pears and sunflower
seeds and tomatoes and other raw food to find out what effect that would have. And when Art
Robinson left, Pauling, of course, was interested in finding out how this work was going. And he asked
me to, I believe the first project that he asked me specifically to get involved in was to calculate
the amount of certain micronutrients in the food that these mice were fed. Because as scientists,
we tend to be a little reductionist, we want to find out if there is an effect with the whole
food, then what is it in the food that might be protective? So that was a very challenging
project that Pauling gave to me. And I was a bit frustrated because the way that the food had been
provided to the mice made it very difficult to determine how much an individual mouse consumed
of any particular food stuff. The mice were also caged five to a cage. And there were social
patterns that developed of hierarchy that developed within the cage. So there were dominant mice
who would eat the preferred food and then the less dominant mice would get what was left. So
there was some competition for the best food, the most flavorful food for the mice.
The way the food was provided to them was sometimes as a mush ground up or blended food and
sometimes as chunks of carrots and pears and so forth. The sunflower seeds were given to them
in small glass containers with metal lids that had a hole in them. And the mice would spray the
sunflower seeds out all over the place. And it was really impossible to determine the intake of
any of these foods for specific animal. And even for a cage of animals divided by five was really
not appropriate calculation. There was a lot of waste so a lot of the food would fall through the
mesh to the floor to the cage rack. And sometimes they would defecate and urinate in the sunflower
seed container as well and then wouldn't continue to eat once they'd already defecated or urinated
in that container. There were other issues as well. For instance the vitamin A content of carrots
can differ appreciably depending upon how long the carrots are stored after they've been picked.
And that was something that was not measured at the time. So there was no analysis,
biochemical analysis of the food that was provided to the animals. And depending upon the variety,
ripeness, length of time something had been stored whether it was refrigerated or stored at room
temperature. The micronutrient content of the food stuffs provided to the mice could very
appreciably. So I made the calculations and I sat down with Linus Pauling and told him that in my
estimation it was really impossible to glean any really useful detailed information about the
micronutrient intake of these animals and that the best we could do was say that the raw food
diet seemed to be protective but it was it was just too difficult to determine what constituents in
the raw food diet conferred that protection. So it was a little bit, I was a little bit ambivalent
about that. I think I did a very thorough and good job in making these determinations but ultimately
what I had to say was a little bit disappointing I think.
Oh he didn't react with disappointment. He reacted as I was presenting him with facts and
calculations and he was very seemed very pleased to get the information. It was not long after that
that you and Cameron began spending quite a lot more time at the institute and I believe they'd
taken an apartment nearby maybe Redwood City and Cameron of course was very interested in
high dose vitamin C as a junk to therapy and cancer as was Pauling and they had done some clinical
work together over the years beginning probably in 1971-1972 so it even preceded the founding
of the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine. And Cameron was concerned with some of the
practical issues about the administration of high dose vitamin C to cancer patients who might
also be taking chemotherapy drugs and we know that vitamin C has some general detoxification
properties and Cameron specifically was concerned that if people were taking chemotherapy drugs
then should they take high dose vitamin C at the same time which might have an effect on the
efficacy of the chemotherapy drugs. So he didn't want to recommend to people that they take
high dose vitamin C while taking chemotherapy if the vitamin C was going to somehow adversely affect
these drugs. So he wanted to find a way to study this and in association with Linus Pauling and
Alan Sheetz we came up with the idea of using fish toxicology experiments which is a pretty well
established model for studying pollution in streams and lakes and bodies of water and things
like that. So we read a lot about fish toxicology Alan and I figured out how to reconstitute water
from distilled water by adding back certain salts to provide the proper habitat for fingerling trout.
And the idea was that we would have fingerling trout that would be exposed to vitamin C and
chemotherapy drugs dissolved in their water that they were living in and we would monitor any
observable effects in the fish and we hypothesized that they would be detected by abnormal behavior
in the fish which would have to do with the way they swim the distance that they cover in a certain
period of time and so forth. So there was some technology that was also developed to make these
kinds of measurements. So that was another project that I worked with you and Cameron Inline
as Pauling. Unfortunately we had to vacate the building at 2700 Sandhill Road in Menlo Park
ostensibly because there had been cracks in the building due to small earthquakes over time.
It wasn't a building that was set on bedrock it was on loose soil and the landlord wanted to
get the tenants out make some structural corrections in the building and I don't think the landlord
was overly excited by a laboratory in the building anyway. We were sharing the building with
Kemper insurance company and I think he was more happy with having nice dry insurance company
and having wet labs there with animal experiments and physics experiments and so forth.
So those experiments had to be wrapped up before we really brought them to fruition before we move
to the facility at 440 Page Mill Road in Palo Alto.
Were there other scientific collaborations with Pauling and over the course of your relationship?
There were. He would come into my office from time to time and we would talk about
ideas he had different projects that he was interested in. Occasionally he would ask me if I
would be interested in doing something like writing a book review which was a little surprising but
when Evelyn Richards book of Vitamin C in Cancer Medicine or Politics was published I believe in 1991
or 1992 Linus Pauling came into my office with a copy of the book and asked me if I would be
interested in writing a book review to be submitted to a nutrition journal and I of course said yes
and wrote the review which was subsequently published in a nutrition journal. Later
and of course I would go into his office from time to time and talk with him about different things.
The quantum chemist by the name of Zele Kermit who was collaborating with Pauling and
Problems in Theoretical Chemistry and Physics over the whole period in the late 1970s through Pauling's
death. Zele Kermit and I were both rock hounds. We had collected rocks and minerals when we were
kids and we knew that Pauling was was a great mineralologist and understood a lot about the
silicate minerals which are quite interesting so the three of us would amuse ourselves occasionally by
Zele Kermit and I would bring in some of our mineral specimens and we would sit in Pauling's office
and try to stump the expert essentially. Sometimes Zele Kermit and I would have forgotten the
identifications of some of the minerals we had so they would be presented to Dr. Pauling to see if
he could identify them and it was astonishing because even though he had probably not thought about
some of these things in many many years or even decades he infallibly was able to identify the
mineral and make a fairly quick identification so that was fun. It didn't have anything to do with
any of the research going on at the institute but it was it was very fun to to sit and talk with him
in that way. Later in the late 1980s and I'm going to say probably around 1988 Pauling came into my
office with an idea for a new technique to fabricate superconductive material and this was
during kind of a heyday of resurgence of interest in ceramic superconductors but Pauling had a
vastly different idea which had to do with the way a material could be fabricated and perhaps
that would raise the temperature which would be superconductive and it had to do with
excuse me phone on dampening and his idea was that if you could have a conductive metal
like tin drawn to an incredibly fine fibrill as he called it maybe 10 or 20 angstroms in diameter
surrounded by insulating material like glass then the superconductive temperature of the tin
would be increased the TC of the tin would be raised and he talked with me about some ideas
that he had and how to make this material which he believed would be important in supporting a
patent application that he wanted to file and his goal I think in filing this patent application
as he described it to me and others was to generate a stable revenue source for the institute
so he wasn't interested in acquiring wealth on his own but he was interested in looking for
revenue sources for the institute which had lurched from one financial crisis to another
throughout my whole tenure at the Oinas Bong Institute of Science and Medicine and he thought
that this might be something that could be licensed and would generate lots of income so Zella
Kermann and I set up a laboratory Stanford industrial park at a least facility that the institute
had on Porter Drive which also has the Susakawa aging research facility and some storage area
and we set up a laboratory bought an oven some torches blow torches compress gas borosilicate glass
tin and Zee could develop a very interesting way to collect the material that we were going to
produce which was a bicycle inverted on a block of wood and we had taken the rubber tire off
the bike rim and we wanted to collect this glass clad fibrill of tin that we would generate
with torches above the furnace and then connect it to the bicycle wheel and then
use the pedals or a crank to turn the bicycle rim and then we would collect in a circular
fashion this long piece of glass that was filled with tin. So there was a lot of trial and error
involved in that and you and Kermann was aware of what we were doing as well and he developed
kind of a special interest in this as well so you and Kermann and Zella Kermann and I spent
quite a lot of time in this laboratory at Porter Drive trying to produce this material and it was
interesting in another way as well in that Pauline was very interested in seeing the laboratory
notebooks and wanted to be sure that we were taking copious and meticulous notes on what we were
doing and the laboratory notebook page for instance had to be signed and dated and then periodically
I believe once a week or once every two weeks someone who was not associated with the project was
asked to read what had been put in the laboratory notebook and countersign it so typically we asked
Emil Zucacamba who was the president of the institute at that time to read what we'd written in
the lab notebook and then he would countersign it and dated as well which was when I was working
as a scientist at the institute I think I was aware of how important it is to maintain good
protocol and filling out data and laboratory notebooks you don't erase things you cross them out
glue or tape things and use pen date and so forth so that in the future people who are unfamiliar
with your work could theoretically be able to go back and repeat what you'd done based only on
the information provided in the lab notebook and that was that concept was really driven home
through this work for Linus Pauline because he was very interested in us maintaining
very meticulous laboratory notebook which we did he was quite happy with it and after many months
of trial and error and kind of a sophisticated development of this technique and examination of
the product through high power magnification we were able to come up with material that we thought
would be suitable needed to be tested of course to see whether or not the superconductive temperature
had changed but Pauline was just ecstatic at that time he was in an apartment in Stanford and
we Zeke and I were very excited and we brought a sample of this down to his apartment and
he himself was very excited it was it was I can imagine that he exhibited this kind of
emotion many times throughout his life whenever he made an important scientific discovery or
became aware of an important discovery that influenced his own work but he just looked joyful
and he immediately went over to the mantle on fireplace and got a big cubic pyrate crystal and
gave one to me and gave something to Zeke and then said be sure to bring your copies of General
Chemistry in and unscribed them on the occasion of this happy discovery and invention that we've
made and that work formed the basis for his patent application and I believe his patent for
novel technique for fabricating superconductive material was awarded in perhaps 1991 I think
to where initial applications submitted as early as 1988-1989 but I think that the final application
was the final patent was granted in 1991. Was that technique ever employed on any of them?
Well it would turn out to be very difficult to measure changes in superconductivity
in this material because if you can imagine getting an appropriate contact between
the end of this tin fibro that was maybe 10 to 20 angstroms in diameter was extremely difficult.
We sent the material off to General Electric and connected he Pauling had
contacted a number of his friends in industry to find out if they had equipment that might be
capable of measuring making these measurements for us so there were problems in actually making
the measurements but the vice president of the institute Rick Hicks at the time felt that since
we had the patent in hand we should try to license it so he embarked on a process of
trying to identify companies in the United States that might be interested in licensing
this technology and he wasn't having much success in this country he went to Japan I believe in
probably about 1991 or 1992 and tried to shop it around there also without I'm sure there was
interest expressed but there was nothing that was really consummated at the time and it led to
kind of an interesting exchange sometime later when Rick had returned from Asia some months had
gone by Emil Zucacondo called me on the intercom if I would come down to his office because we had
a visitor and I went down to his office and we had someone there from the Central Intelligence
Agency who was very interested in this particular invention and wanted to know why we were
shopping this around in Japan and in other countries rather than the United States and I explained
to him that well the reason was we hadn't been able to find anyone in the United States who was
interested I thought it was quite interesting that the CIA seemed to know about this
and that was the end of that that was pretty much the end of that I think there was a misq
later that had to do with the turmoil surrounding Pauling's death and succession of people in
charge of the institute and files being shifted around and so forth and somehow the application to
continue the maintenance fee on that particular patent fell through the cracks so I think that
I think the reason that it died effectively was because the maintenance fee was not paid
unfortunately.
Not really I think that the vitamin C and skin cancer experiments of course I was co-author of
one of the papers that resulted from that work and in the superconductive material were
two major collaborations. How do you describe Coins' style of the scientists and what do you
observe where I think the greatest strengths of the scientists? Well he as many people have
remarked had an encyclopedic knowledge of physics chemistry biology perhaps medicine
mathematics statistics had an incredibly good grasp of statistics and that served
him very well I think as a scientist because he was as I like to say perhaps the best embodiment
of the multidisciplinary or interdisciplinary attack on scientific problems and of course that's
a buzz word in science today and that's what the NIH and funding agencies encourage is kind of
team activity but it was remarkable that this kind of knowledge expansive and encyclopedic
knowledge was exhibited in one particular person in the in Linus Pauling which I think was quite
remarkable. So his memory as well his ability to extract references and facts and material from
other papers and so forth that span most of his life was quite remarkable so I think those two
things served him incredibly well as a scientist and I saw that in action many times when he could
cite other literature and talk about what other people had found and so forth so I was very
impressed by his grasp of science and his memory and he also struck me as being very courageous.
As I said earlier my first exposure to him in the political arena I thought he was quite courageous
at that time later I became aware of just how courageous he was when he was facing the US Senate
with respect to allegations of his lack of patriotism or something like that and he basically
stood them down which I thought was incredibly courageous and in another sense he was a very courageous
scientist when Zullic and I were working with this furnace in the late 1980s at Porter Drive. Pauling
would come up from time to time and one time in particular he put on a lab coat and put on gloves
and goggles and was wielding the torch above the 800 degree furnace as well so he was actively
engaged in this experimental project which I thought was quite extraordinary so he didn't
really prefer to just sit at his desk and think about things he also wanted to get hands on when
something really intrigued him or interested him and during the mouse skin cancer experiments as
well he would often come through the laboratory just to check on things see how things were going
asked people questions about the work that was underway and so forth so he was not removed from
the experimental side of things although clearly he was involved in a lot of other things and didn't
actually participate physically in a lot of the experimental work in those days he he didn't
he wasn't a stranger in the laboratory and I witnessed that first hand with the work on
superconductivity where he actually was engaged experimentally and I think that was probably the last
experimental work that he was engaged in because at that time he probably would have been in his
late 1980 this was the late 1980s so he was in his late 80s as well.
Over time you your role leads to change from that of scientific researcher to more of
the administrator and I'm wondering if you engage in other different kinds of work with Pauling
in that context that was demonstrated. Very much so I had asked I had been asked to become
an assistant to the president when he meals at the was president of the institute. At the time I
was co-director with a meal of the laboratory for research and gene regulation and we had a small
research group we were looking at problems and cancer metastasis using protein profiling techniques
which had just recently been developed and we were developing instrumentation that would allow us
to increase reproducibility and reduce noise in the experimental procedure and we were very
interested in discovering genes and proteins that might correlate with the metastatic the
development of the metastatic phenotype in both marine and human cancer cells. Excuse me
so I was also working a bit administratively with a meal of zucocondle at that time and then when
a meal retired from the institute on the occasion of his birthday there was quite a lot of
turmoil at the institute because there are a number of problems one problem was the institute as I
mentioned earlier had a history of financial instability and over the years under e-mails direction
the institute expanded quite significantly to include some projects that probably would not be
considered strictly in the realm of orthomolecular medicine of course which was Paulings most
I think the reason he set up the institute to begin with and something that he felt strongest about
so I think a meal may have had a desire for the institute to become a more comprehensive
institute of molecular biological and chemical and biological sciences similar to the
Salkins institute down in southern California which is a fine template but there weren't
enough grants one by institute staff to support all the varied activities that were going on
so concomitant with e-mails retirement and retirement of Rick Hicks from the institute there was
a shift in focus in the institute and the board of trustees decided that there really weren't
enough funds to sustain all the varied programs underway at the institute so the idea was to
pair back some of the strictly molecular biological work that wasn't funded extramarially by government
grants from DOE or NIH or NCI or whatever and refocus specifically on orthomolecular medicine
and at about that time Linus Pauling had begun a friendship and scientific collaboration
with a German cardiologist Matthias Rat who together with Pauling had developed some interesting
hypotheses about the relationship of lipoprotein A which is a risk factor for atherosclerosis
and a major constitutive atherosclerotic plaque and vitamin C and they published a number of
hypothesis papers a very famous one being in PNAS and developed decided to set up a laboratory for
cardiovascular disease research that was directed by Dr. Rat and Pauling was very excited about this
work when and at some point and I don't remember the exact time but it was after a meal had retired
and Pauling became for short time the president and director of the institute after a meal
he asked me to become his assistant and I wasn't quite sure what that meant so I had written him
note or memo asking him what he wanted me to do and I had some ideas mainly of administrative nature
as to things that I thought could result in in big improvements in the way the institute was
was run and our status financial status and other issues but he disappeared to Big Sur to his
ranch down on the coast of California for some time and I felt a little adrift and at by this
time I had gotten to know Linus Plain Jr fairly well because he was I think in the process of
getting more actively involved in the administration and the institute because he recognized his
father was ill and there were a lot of problems at the institute and he felt he should step in
to help his father which I thought was very commendable and eventually I became the executive officer
at the institute which was similar in function to being president of the institute and then later
the board appointed me chief executive officer I think in about 1993 technically I became chief
executive officer so throughout this period where I functioned in different administrative roles
I worked very closely with Linus Plain Jr the Board of Trustees and of course by that time
Linus Plain had become chairman of the Board of Trustees and director of research at the institute
but didn't really have an administrative role any longer in the Linus Plain Institute of Science and
Medicine because I think everyone felt that it would be best if he were spared the problems that
we had to resolve and there were problems concerning relocation it was a zoning issue where the
least property on which our building was situated at 440 page mill road in Palo Alto was scheduled to
change from commercial to residential zoning quite quickly and no long range plans had really
been developed to deal with that zoning change and we didn't have an endowment had very little money
so the prospect of moving the institute trying to keep it intact in the mid peninsula but paying
maybe 10 or 20 times more in rent was not very encouraging and Linus Plain himself of course had
been diagnosed with prostate cancer and although he was undergoing a number of different experimental
therapies it was not believed that he would survive his illness and we were very concerned about
what would happen to the institute after his death would we be able to continue to raise money
to support the institute as a viable research organization and then of course there were lawsuits
and there was quite a lot of litigation at that time Matthias Rat had left the institute and it
sued the institute for infringement in his business activities and also sued Linus Pauling so I
had to manage a lot of our litigation at that time as well so my role at the time the big
challenges were finding a future home or at least the disposition of the Linus Plain is to do
the science and medicine keeping it intact and reputable and also managing our litigation which
was very burdensome and took absorbed a lot of my time and a lot of the boards time as well
but Pauling was largely spared from that I mean he was deposed of course a number of times but
I managed a lot of our legal affairs at that time in close association when Linus Plain
Jr was the chairman of the board and at that time we had very regular board meetings as well so
the board of trustees was kept well-apprised of all the activities and their opinions were
solicited in many of these activities as well so it was a very challenging time for me I was
surprised to be honest when the board asked me to become chief executive officer because it kind
of came out of the blue the work that I was doing with a musica condo was not really related to
orthomolecular medicine wasn't related to vitamin C at the time as I said we were looking at
metastatic cancer which really had nothing to do with orthomolecular medicine so I was concerned
my group and my job were in jeopardy as well because there were rumors circulating that
the board wanted to refocus on orthomolecular medicine and since my work wasn't involved in
orthomolecular medicine I thought perhaps I might be laid off from the institute as well
at about the same time a musica condo wanted to collect some of the people who were doing
molecular biological work in a new institute called the Institute of Molecular Medical Sciences
which he hoped to rent space from the Linus-Planning Institute of Science and Medicine in the same
building so I spent quite a lot of time as executive officer with Zele Kerman analyzing that
proposition trying to figure out whether it was practical and if so how building expenses should
be shared between the two groups and so forth so I spent quite a lot of time in those kinds of
deliberations at that time too and eventually we came up with a recommendation to Linus-Planning
in the board. One of Pauline's some calling cards of Caltech anyway then the Golden Year
and Caltech was his ability to collect and marshal and oversee tremendous talent of scientific
researches or the graduate students or postdocs and I'm wondering if you have there this and one sort of
dynamic going on and over the course of the time I don't get it with his ability to collect talent and
make it efficient productive. Well I think our Robinson is a terrific scientist and art of course
was working very closely with Linus-Planning at the University of California San Diego and then
came up to run his lab and collaborate with research at Stanford and there's no question that
Dr. Robinson was an extraordinarily capable scientist and with Pauline developed lots of very
interesting ideas so that was one person that he worked with over that period of time that I had
a lot of respect for and I think Pauline had a lot of respect for at least until there was a
big schism that developed between them which was very painful to watch especially at that time I
was not really privy to a lot of the major administrative decisions at the institute so it was a
little unclear as to why this conflict had developed but it was very difficult an uncomfortable time
for everyone I think at the institute. Excuse me. Bill Aberg, I'm Bill Aberg, physicist was also
very extraordinarily talented individual who was developing the mass spectrometer for
metabolite profiling. Emil Zucacondle who had developed the idea of chemical paleogenetics or
molecular evolution with Pauline earlier in the 1960s was an extraordinarily bright capable scientist.
He was also the founding editor of the journal of molecular evolution and was
one of those rare individuals who's capable of sustaining simultaneously many complex thoughts and I
saw this in action many times I have tremendous respect and admiration for Emil Zucacondle he's
really an extraordinary scientist and theorist so yes there were people of extraordinarily high
caliber that were involved with the institute and of course there were collaborations as well
in some of Pauline's collaborators who would visit the institute from time to time.
There were a few problems in that since the institute did not have stable financial resources
or an endowment it was difficult to attract high caliber scientists. There were high caliber
scientists who were employed at the institute John Levit, Jim Fleming, Greg Spicer,
there were a number of people that were very very good you and Cameron as a medical director
but it was difficult because not much could be offered to people other than at will contract which
was the way that most contract most employment is handled in California unless you have an employment
contract and it was imprudent to offer employment contracts to people so initially it was kind
of an implied at will employment arrangement with people and then later in the early 1990s it
became very explicit at will employment relationship with employees but nevertheless there were people
who were attracted to the institute because of Linus Pong because of his interest in vitamin C
Dr. Connie Chow and others who did a lot of really terrific work Wulcott.com just to mention
a few but there were a number of really excellent people there physicians and scientists who did a
lot of very good work over the years and in those days it was also very difficult to get expect and
get funding from the National Institutes of Health or the National Cancer Institute for the kind
of work that Pauline was especially interested in which had to do with vitamin C in cancer so I'm
sure you're aware of his difficulty in getting grants to carry out this kind of research with the
very promising clinical work that Cameron had been doing in Scotland Pauline and Cameron went to
the NCI with that work repeatedly and they suggested that he applied for funds to do animal work
and soul culture work and he applied for those funds and was turned down repeatedly over seven
or eight consecutive years so the money that was supported that kind of work at the institute was
sought from the public through this direct mail solicitation campaign and that was the money that
was available to pay the researchers who were doing that work.
We'll close it now in an hour if you didn't do it okay.
Yeah.
Pauline is remembering to also famously being a terrific lecture and I wonder if you could come in on that
your experience and see him in lecture and his facility in that regard.
Yes.
I didn't see him lecture very often.
I saw him give lectures at Stanford University and of course he would give the famous vitamin C
lecture where he would stand on stage and pull from his...
He typically wore a three-piece suit when he was giving a lecture, a dark suit, sometimes
he would wear his beret and he would invariably begin his lectures on vitamin C by pulling out
a vial, a test tube and holding it up with his fingers with a very small amount of a white
powder at the bottom that was barely detectable from the audience perspective and you would say
this represents the RDA for vitamin C. This is the amount of vitamin C that the food nutrition
board believes that people should get every day and he would follow that by pulling
out a large test tube with 13 grams of vitamin C in it and you could obviously see all this white
powder and the vial from across the auditorium and he would say this is the amount of vitamin C
that a goat synthesizes on average every day. I think goats know more about nutrition than the
food nutrition board and of course that always got a big round of applause and chuckles from the
audience. One lecture I saw him give which really stood out in my mind was a lecture,
departmental lecture to biostatistics at Stanford and that department was chaired by Byron Brown
who was a leading biostatistician and the Stanford Department of Biostatistics is World
Renown. They've been World Renown for many decades and Byron Brown was the father of a classmate
in mind from Stanford so I knew him and he had become aware of Pauling's work with Abraham
Hofer on a regiment provided adjunctively to cancer patients which included not only vitamin C
but also B vitamins, vitamin E zinc and some other things and Pauling and Hofer had published two
papers on this regiment and Pauling believed that it was even more effective than the sole use of
vitamin C which was given either intravenously or orally sometimes both by Ewing Kermit and Scotland.
And they had and Pauling had developed a statistical analysis of this data based on work done by an
old friend of his from UC Berkeley by the name of Harden Jones and Pauling believed that this
statistical analysis was better than the standard Kaplan Meyer mortality analysis because by using
Harden Jones analysis you could actually resolve sub cohorts that had similar death rates
and you might be able to learn more about these sub cohorts with with similar death rates.
So he thought that this was was a better way to analyze mortality data from from clinical studies
and he published also I think was Ella Kermann and perhaps it was PNAS on this Harden Jones
analysis of mortality data and he was invited by Byron Brown to give a lecture to the
biostatisticians at Stanford on this Harden Jones mortality data and of course at the time everybody
was using Kaplan Meyer which is the standard step staircase type curve that you see published in
papers and I went with Pauling and Herman to that lecture which was in a large conference
in Harvard Stanford and it was astonishing how little criticism he got from this analysis.
I think he was prepared to be well he was never really defensive about anything because he was
very sure was on intelligence and his own analysis but no one had any serious criticisms of his
analysis and people were saying that well perhaps we should we should look at this more carefully
and perhaps this does offer a better alternative to Kaplan Meyer analysis in some circumstances.
It was quite extraordinarily quite extraordinary to see some of the world's leading biostatisticians
react that way to something that was fairly novel and and something that was certainly not
standardly employed in in this kind of analysis and it was quite interesting to see him present
present that analysis.
I wonder if you could speak a little bit more about Pauling in the mentor as well as your
software and others as well.
He was very encouraging and as I said he was not a Louvre so he was very easy person to speak with.
I think at the time that I got to know him of course he was in his 80s and at that time he was
considered kind of an icon in science and everyone was extraordinarily respectful to Linus Pauling.
No one at the institute called him by his first name for instance it was always Professor Pauling
or Dr. Pauling even Dorothy Monroe the secretary and assistant called him Dr. Pauling and
typically Zele Kerman would call him Professor Pauling. Emile Zucacondo typically called him Dr. Pauling
as did Rick Hickson. So there I think that was a measure of respect that all the people at the
institute had for him. He was also very interested in people on a personal basis as well and
I remember when he had decided not to drive so much himself anymore from his apartment on
Stanford campus to the institute which was just a a mile or two away. People would volunteer to
drive him from his apartment to the institute and then take him back to his apartment at the end of
the day and I did that quite often because I enjoyed talking with him and I also enjoyed to have
an uninterrupted period with him where he was free from telephone calls and appointments and
other distractions because there were a lot of demands on his time throughout his career I imagine
and at the institute there were always people calling wanting to interview him wanting him to give
lectures and so forth and wanting to visit him so it was rare to have an occasion to actually
talk with him one-on-one with no distractions and he would occasionally ask me about my long-term
aspirations and make suggestions and he would often tell me stories. He loved to tell stories
about things that had happened to him that were based on work that we were doing at the institute
or that might have been stimulated by a comment I would make to him and I remember one time
this is a little off topic because it doesn't have anything to do with mentorship but I think it
gives you some insight into his sense of humor during one of these trips where I was taking him to
the institute. He told me that he had been over at the Stanford Library to look at an old issue
of nature or science from close to the early part of the 20th century close to the turn of the
century and this was when David Star Jordan was president of Stanford University, Leland Stanford
who was chairman of the board, David Star Jordan was an ornithologist excuse me Iqtheologist
who had written books on academic books on fish and he was president of the university at that time
as well as being a scholar and Pauling had been looking through an old issue of nature and
for a specific article but this other story caught his eye and it had to do with a controversy that
had developed at Stanford between David Star Jordan and Leland Stanford and Leland Stanford apparently
had become unhappy with David Star Jordan because during trustees meetings Jordan did not refer
the trustees by name and Stanford thought that this was not civil and perhaps even borderline
rude not to refer to them by name and he had implored Jordan to learn the names of the trustees
and in subsequent meetings to refer to them by name and Jordan's retort apparently to Stanford
was well I'm afraid if I enforce to memorize the name of a trustee I'll forget the name of a fish
and Pauling thought that was hilarious and it gives you an idea of what he valued
because I think he was definitely on the side of Jordan in that argument
oh there were lots of other stories one time it wasn't during a drive but it was when
I was negotiating in contract with Unilever and Elizabeth Arden who had decided to develop a line
of cosmetics that included some antioxidants and wanted to get the institute involved in this
not in a research and development capacity but they wanted to support some research at the institute
and provide us with a lot of money and I've been talking many times with Linus Pauling about
this prospect and went in to talk with him in his office about it and he said oh he remembered
one time that he and Abe Helen had gone to visit Lord Leaver in England and had brought along
a bottle of scotch whiskey as a present and it was in their bag and they got to Lord Leaver's
castle or home and they were met by servants who immediately took their bags and they were
ushered in to see Lord Leaver and Pauling and his wife were chatting with him and Pauling
remembered that he had a gift so he wanted to excuse himself and go to his room and get the gift
for Lord Leaver and he went up to his room and the servants had already unpacked their bags
put clothes in the drawers or hanging in the closet and they'd also taken out the bottle of whiskey
and uncapped it and had two jiggers there ready for Pauling and his wife
because they believed that Pauling had brought this along to serve himself
so he thought it was very funny that he had to present Lord Leaver with a bottle of whiskey
that had already been opened but he explained to him why it had been open and one other story
that I thought was quite indicative of Pauling's character was told to me by you and Cameron
and Cameron of course had been collaborating very closely with Pauling and Pauling had decided to
visit Cameron as home and walk one inside on a trip that he was making to England and Cameron
told me that he was a little bit ambivalent about this visit by the great man of science
to his humble home in Scotland and he was worried that it wouldn't be presentable enough so he and
his wife made elaborate preparations to welcome Linus Pauling and his wife to their their humble
home in Scotland and the day that Pauling arrived Pauling arrived and within half an hour before
Pauling had arrived the toilet stopped up and Cameron hadn't had time to do anything about it before
the arrival of Linus Pauling and his wife so Pauling and his wife arrived and they came in and
the pleasantries were exchanged and Cameron showed them around the home and the view and so forth
and Pauling asked to use the bathroom and Cameron said which I'm very very sorry it's characteristic
way but there seems to be a problem with the toilet and Pauling so what's the problem and Cameron
explained to him the toilet had just gotten stopped up and hadn't had time to do anything and Pauling
said well let's go in and fix it so Cameron was a bit of gasp but said okay so the two of them went
into the bathroom and Pauling cut down with a with a wrench and Cameron had the plumbers helper
and Pauling had a wrench and he was lying on the floor with working on the plumbing fixing
Cameron's toilet so Cameron realized that he didn't really need to be too careful about what he
said or how Pauling was treated after that because he recognized that Pauling was was not a
and a luke cerebral sort of person who didn't get his hand dirty so to speak so
he mentioned one year maybe the first experience upon you had was of him doing it
that operated in DC politics and I'm wondering if you could put a little bit more on what you saw it
and then you said that it was a piece of activism and a political thought of it and of course the ending year
well of course I myself was very much opposed to the Vietnam War my brother was killed there
as a fighter pilot in 1970 which really almost interfered with me resuming my studies at Stanford
because it was emotionally very difficult time and I had never understood the logic of the war
I didn't buy that domino theory that the administration time was was promoting with respect to
we need stock communism Vietnam because then all all the countries in southeast Asia will become
communist and Indonesian and Japan might be attacked and so forth I didn't buy that explanation
and it seemed to me that the war had been going on for a very long time and was resulting in a lot
of misery and I couldn't see how it was constructive I couldn't see a good outcome so I I think had
sentiments that were very similar to those espoused by the line is Pauling at the time
and Pauling of course as I learned had been an old hand in political activism originally
stimulated by his concern about proliferation of nuclear weapons and medical concerns about
the effect of widespread fallout from atomic bomb testing in the atmosphere so that that really
resonated very strongly with me there were some people at the institute who were even further left
and I would consider myself in some ways conservative in many ways liberal as well but there were some
people at the institute who were I would say probably extreme leftist and I remember in particular
after one of Pauling's talks at Stanford that was peace related there was quite a lot of
unhappiness among some people because Pauling had made the statement during this talk that
he believed that the retention of some nuclear weapons by both the Soviet Union and the United
States and the so-called mutually assured destruction principle had actually resulted perhaps in
deterrent from having a nuclear war conflagration so they were they were surprised to hear him say
that because I think some people had hoped that he would espouse the opinion that we should destroy
all weapons you know laterally and so forth but that's not what he said in his lecture he said
that he believed that having some of these weapons by opposing forces would have probably resulted
in the satisfactory stalemate because either side was inhibited from using them knowing what
would result from that first use of an atomic weapon. That was a independent method that you
developed pretty early on in the 60s like the 60s in Paul? Yeah and I heard him say that several times
so he definitely was not I would say he wasn't a pacifist because he said many times the World
War II was well justified and he as you know worked closely with the military to develop armaments
and instruments that helped the Allied effort during World War II and he was certainly opposed to
Hitler and Nazism and I always saw him as a great patriot and it never occurred to me that
great patriotism and opposition to the Vietnam War or opposition to
atmospheric testing of nuclear weapons was somehow couldn't be reconciled and some people
they didn't seem to be to be mutually exclusive characteristics.
Pauline was not someone who engaged often in small talk? So even in the many discussions that I
had with him he wasn't someone who liked to talk about pop culture or movies or music or literature
or anything of that nature. He loved to talk about science and especially about things that he
was interested in and he loved to tell stories and most of the stories were related to things that
interested him from a scientific basis. So I don't recall ever talking with him specifically
about any political activities and unfortunately I never thought to ask him more closely about
some of his political activities because there were always other things to talk about and
I didn't really query him much about his personal history when I knew him we were always talking
about current things or things that we were going to be doing in the future and not so much
retrospective issues except when he would tell me stories based on a current stimulating
conversation that we might be having but no he didn't generally talk about political issues with
staff. It was mainly related to administrative issues and scientific issues.
What was he like in larger social settings?
Well in larger social settings he was often the person that people gravitated to. He had a
real charismatic personality kind of a magnetic personality. He always had a big smile. He was very
engaging, very warmly greeted people in a social setting, was physical, shook hands, put his arm
around people. So he was very engaging and people responded to that and that's why so many people
loved him over the years and when he died in 1994 the institute collected hundreds and hundreds
of cards from people that didn't know Linus playing personally but had been deeply affected by
his death and were grieving and sharing their grief with us at the time and everyone at the
institute felt the same way as well. I mean it was a really when he died in 1994 it was a very
emotional moment for all of us because he just he had a way of generating a lot of positive
emotion about him and a lot of people loved him and respected him for different reasons but
he was a very jovial person. As I said he treated everyone fairly and equally. I remember one time
when I was in the back parking lot of the institute, Pauling was leaving the back door
and the janitor was arriving so it was after hours it was maybe 530 or 6 in the afternoon and the
janitor was quite away from the door. I'd say maybe a hundred feet from the door because janitor
tended to park at the far end of the parking lot and Pauling stood there holding the door open
for probably three or four minutes while the janitor navigated this distance and came into the
building and then Pauling greeted him and then left the door and he was also holding a box because
he often used a box to ferry books and papers back and forth from the institute to his apartment
or ranch so he had something in his arm as well and stood there holding the door for the janitor
and I think that was kind of symbolic in a way of the way he treated people. He was just very
fair to everyone. Sometimes I think his excitement about scientific ideas that he would generate
an association with particular people caused him perhaps to overlook what some other people might
consider problematic issues and personalities and I think that this happened to him at least twice
in his later years at the institute and both times it resulted in personal clashes, very
unamicable departures of personnel from the institute and litigation which was very difficult,
expensive and painful for everyone involved but I think he was so excited by scientific talent that
he tended to overlook some personality characteristics from time to time but as I said he was a very
warm engaging person. I would go to birthday celebrations which occurred I think every five years
typically at hotel in San Francisco and there were other occasions at which visitors were
honored or the humanitarian award was given out or other awards were given out or Pauling was
an attendance for an award and he was always very charming and people were very happy to see him
and he always had a big smile and greeting for everyone. Well the birthday celebrations were
terrific. The last one I remember was at Stanford Court Hotel in San Francisco the Mistress of
Ceremonies was Rita Moreno and I believe she was approached by Rick Hicks to host that party because
she had gotten an Emmy, an OB, a Tony and an Academy Award so Rick thought it was
appropriate that someone who had been so honored in so many of the performing fields was hosting
an event for someone who had been so honored in so many medical and scientific and social fields
like Linus Pauling and she was a real firecracker and I think Linus Pauling really enjoyed listening
to her talk and he had a lot of his old friends there and it was it was always he always really enjoyed
interacting with old colleagues. We also had a 20th anniversary celebration of the Linus Pauling
Institute in 1993 at the Ringgstorf House which was a Victorian house that had been renovated
in the Saltmarsh area of Mountain View, California, adjacent to Palo Alto and that was an
opportunity to put on display a lot of Pauling's awards, medals, honorary degrees and also invite
supporters of the institute, institute staff and friends and some of Pauling's colleagues and
friends who were still in the Bay Area to come and see him and as it turned out it was probably
the last time that some of these people had an opportunity to meet him to see him again.
Owen Chamberlin was there, Harden McConnell from Stanford, chemistry department had been a long
friend of Pauling's and I think instrumental in bringing Pauling to Stanford back in 1969
was there Byron Brown from Biosatistics was there and there were a number of people that Pauling
had liked and associated with over the years that were there and it provided him an opportunity
to see them and greet them. He always had a lot of energy to meet people as well and
it a very interesting way of speaking. It was very characteristic and a very characteristic way
of moving as well both of which were captured quite realistically by John Aston when he performed
the part of Linus Pauling in the nature of the Marital Bond which was a play put on in association
when the Linus Pauling exhibition years ago.
What about that note? Outside of Boyd Des and May the Hall we don't really have a good sense of
who Pauling's friends really were. He was calling on that on the tagging of the movies they were his friends.
Well he spent quite a lot of time of course with Rick Hicks and Emilsu Kukandall and I think
Rick really went out of his way to try to take care of Linus Pauling as well especially after
A. Valindyde really looked after his welfare and was interested in his personal health as well and
I think even tried to get Linus Pauling to exercise which is something that Pauling refused to do.
He talked quite often with Emilsu Kukandall mainly about administrative issues so with Rick Hicks
and Emilsu Kukandall there was a lot of talk about administrative issues and these kinds of
conversations went on for a decade or longer. He saw quite a lot of hardened McConnell who was someone
he could talk about chemistry with and Henry Talby as well at Stanford and Zellik Herman was
another person that was a colleague and an employee of the institute but someone that Pauling could talk
in a very meaningful detailed way in depth about theoretical chemistry and structural chemistry
and physics so Herman and Pauling co-authored quite a few papers during this period in 1970s through
the 1980s and up to the 1990s and I think Pauling relied on him to do a lot of the sort of the
heavy work in many of those papers so we spent a lot of time with Zellik Herman as well
and there were a lot of people that visited him who he'd known throughout his life
but he didn't really seem to have what I would call a strong social life. Of course if he was
entertaining people at his home in Porto Avali or at his apartment in Stanford I wouldn't necessarily
have known about that. I mean I went to his home in Porto Avali a number of times he and his wife
used to host Christmas parties there and one of the last Christmas parties I went to there I think
was probably 1979. Avali and died in 1980 or 1981? 1981 so I believe that this was probably about
1979 and I remember thinking about the egg nod that Pauling made which was really extraordinary
good. He wasn't a chef but having a Nobel Prize winning chemist Nobel Prize winning chemist
make the egg nod and spike it with with a vodka was pretty extraordinary it was a really terrific
treat and he when he was with his wife was also very affectionate and I think people picked up on
that affection and responded to that as well. After his wife died of course there was no one
for him to be that affectionate with so he was a bit different in in social situations because he
didn't really have someone to to be affectionate with in those circumstances.
Do you have any other recollections that they'd at home? She was a really diminutive person she was
short she was very well spoken very articulate and I enjoyed speaking with her when I talked to her
several times she and I did not talk about science so much as we talked about other issues and
she as I found out later was particularly fond of their association with some of the celebrities
in in Los Angeles and Hollywood during the era in which Pauling was trying to educate them about
radioactive isotopes and nuclear weapons and so forth and engaged in peace activities as well
and we talked I think gave a hell and I talked about those things sometimes but typically she was
very close to her husband physically whenever they were in a social environment and he always
liked to steer the conversation to science so the conversation typically would would end up being
about science and not so much about some of the other activities. One other thing about Pauling
that I enjoyed was when I found out that he enjoyed reading mystery novels I also was a big fan
of Sherlock Holmes and not so much Agatha Christie but particularly Rex Stout and I asked him if he had
read all of Sherlock Holmes and Rex Stout and of course he had so there wasn't anything I could
loan him but there were other books that I was reading he was not familiar with one was called
the Red Right Hand by Joel Townsley Rogers which I think was written in 1939 or 1940 and it's a
real hard boiled great detective story and I loaned that to him and he really he loved that book very
much and he consequently loaned me books I would loan him books and he would he would loan me mystery
books as well that that he had finished reading it was very interesting and in one time he broke
from that orthodoxy and loaning me mystery novels and loaned me a book called Good Night Ava by Richard
Bissell and this was a 1950s pulp paperback with a painted cover and he said I think you'll enjoy this
and I got the book and I read it and it reminded me a little bit of Verscan Caldwell even Mark Twain
maybe and the cover of the book showed kind of a the sultry group sitting on a on a porch of a kind
of a ram shackle cabin probably in the banks of the Mississippi River and there were a couple of
guys lounging around looked like near-do wells and there was a woman's trimming guitar in not much
and she had her foot up on a pickle barrel or something and I thought it was amusing that he'd
loaned me this book and it was actually an amusing entertaining read as well and I gave it back to him
and when he when I gave it back to him his eyes kind of sparkled a bit and he said did you
notice anything particularly funny about the book and I said yes and both of us burst out laughing
he had taken a photograph of his wife and cut out her face and pasted it over the face of the
woman playing guitar on the cover of the book and I thought that was very funny very appropriate
since the book had Eva in the title as well you have that book I'm sure you do yeah
and he had a terrific sense of humor Zella Kerman likes to tell the story of the time that
he was standing at the urinal in the men's room at the Linus Pine Institute Science Medicine and
Linus Pine came in and stood next to him and looked over and said ah we meet his peers
so he was not prudish and of course Ken Hedberg has a very famous story of
when Ken was a graduate student Caltech and was looking through one of those little plastic
viewfinders of the woman O'Neal Turell in a stream standing on a rock or a boulder
he was holding this viewfinder up to the light and he heard Pauling's footsteps outside his
office and thought oh and Pauling came in and of course wanted to see what the viewfinder picture
was and he held the viewfinder up to the light and said ah the salt he identified the rock that
she was standing on so he had a great sense of humor and it would definitely was not prudish
just that I can briefly you mentioned me that Hela is talking about the connections that they
have with some of the Hollywood types do you call any individual which was particularly fun about
the women and stuff that no I don't but I remember there were a number of people who came to
the institute and also to some of Pauling's birthday events and other events such as Eddie
Albert I remember giving a tour to Eddie Albert and son Eddie Albert Jr. one time at the institute
and Carl Sagan came by one time for an event and there were a number of other
number of other people who escaped me right now who came through the institute one reason or another
but those were I believe after Avalon had died so those were people who had continued to have
some title on his pond or the one's point institute but I don't recollect talking with her about
specific people Pauling by all it comes out of very difficult times feeling a bit of a homestead
wondering if you have memories of that time period and how that fit in itself
well as Erick Hall he was gone quite a lot after her death I think he took a trip to Oregon
and visited some of his old boyhood haunts his home maybe the semi-family cemetery maybe
went to Condon came here to Oregon State University he was perhaps didn't exhibit the same sort
of levity that that I was accustomed to seeing in him in other words he was spontaneously happy
in the late 1970s when I saw him he always seemed to be very happy and very carefree I think there
was a more somber demeanor that he exhibited after her death and a lot of the sort of levity
seemed to evaporate from his countenance at that time now that slowly returned over the course
of the 1980s and I'd say by the mid to late 1980s he seemed to be pretty much his old self in
terms of a good sense of humor but there was a period there when he didn't seem to be very happy
okay well we are at an hour and a half and another about half way through my questions
so I don't see a whole day through that yeah that's fine